prudence de violents orages ont éclaté
dans la soirée et d'autres sont attendus
dans la nuit la région d'oran est
particulièrement touchée deux
hélicoptères survolent actuellement la
zone pour procéder à d'éventuelles
évacuations et une cellule de crise a
été mise en place
le reportage de nos confrères de france
3 rend avec le commentaire de william
irigoyen le niveau des eaux est montée
brusquement les orages se sont abattus
peu après 20h sur rouen et ses environs
pour le moment toutes les routes menant
ici à barentin sont impraticables à 10
km du chef-lieu de haute normandie
le bilan est de trois blessés légers
trois voitures se sont encastrées dans
un café une dizaine de maisons ont été
traversés par le courant
ça faisait des vents où l'eau a emporté
ben waters début de la fenêtre la
déshabiller ses côtés s'est ému
deux hélicoptères supplémentaires sont
attendus sur zone ainsi qu'une trentaine
d'hommes de la sécurité civile
la route nationale entre rouen et le
havre a dû être interrompu un train
reliant les deux villes normandes a été
bloqué pendant quelques heures les 130
passagers viennent d'être évacués en bus
météo france a annoncé une nuit agitée
fortement orageuse un communiqué des
ministères de l'équipement de
l'intérieur et de l'aménagement du
territoire recommande d'éviter les
parcours en voiture non indispensables
et de réduire la vitesse sur route et
autoroute dans plusieurs communes de
haute normandie
la direction départementale des affaires
sanitaires et sociales recommande de ne
pas boire l'eau du robinet distribuée
par les réseaux publics